This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你们是在与一位专业的执业人士交流，他非常清楚自己在做什么。有多少男人身披铠甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听着，去学习吧。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在IHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他不会得逞的。他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone, back for another week, another episode discussing, you know, the weird and wonderful things of our 20s and all that they contain. but this week in particular, we're going to talk about such a unique feeling for this decade, for many people who are listening, and that's feeling directionless, feeling really, really lost, not really knowing what you're doing with your life. So I put this kind of poll on my Instagram asking what you guys wanted to hear this week,
在IHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Trust Me, Babe》。欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，又是一周，又是一期节目，我们来讨论一下20多岁时那些奇怪而美妙的事情，以及它们所包含的一切。但本周特别要谈论的是这个十年中一个非常独特的感觉，对于许多正在收听的人来说，那就是感到迷茫，感到非常非常失落，真的不知道自己的人生在做什么。所以我曾在Instagram上发起了一个投票，问你们这周想听什么，
this one by far. So I'm feeling like a lot of the content we're going to talk through today will resonate with quite a few people. who are listening. And if that's you, welcome. Welcome to my kind of mismatch self-help guide as to what you should do when you are feeling directionless when you don't really know where you're going in your life. Why that's completely normal. We are here to reduce shame, reduce stigma. You don't need to know what's going on. And hopefully in this episode, we kind of cover why it's okay to be at this point and be at a kind of juncture in your life. I think a lot of people don't talk about how normal it is to really not know where you're going
这一话题遥遥领先。所以我感觉今天我们要讨论的内容会引起很多听众的共鸣。如果你也是这样，欢迎。欢迎来到我这本有点杂乱的自我帮助指南，告诉你当你感到迷茫、不知道人生方向时该怎么办。为什么这完全正常。我们在这里是为了减少羞耻感，减少污名化。你不需要知道一切都在发生什么。希望在这一集中，我们能涵盖为什么处于人生的这个阶段和节点是没问题的。我认为很多人没有谈论过，不知道自己要去向何方是多么正常的一件事，
to be at a bit of a stalemate. It's definitely a feeling many people get. I've discussed this with my friends quite a lot. And although we're not always at the same point at the same time, I can promise you, I think almost all of them have at some stage in their 20s felt really lost as to where you're going and where they're going. and you might be feeling like, you know, you don't really know what the next step in your life is, feeling helpless, emotionally numb, or like you've kind of lost a bit of energy and a little bit of spark.
处于一种僵局中。这绝对是许多人都会有的感觉。我和朋友们讨论过很多次。虽然我们并不总是在同一时间处于同一点，但我可以向你保证，我想他们几乎所有人在20多岁的某个阶段都曾感到非常迷茫，不知道自己要去向何方。你可能觉得，你知道，你真的不知道人生的下一步是什么，感到无助、情绪麻木，或者感觉自己失去了一点活力和火花。
And many things can make you feel a bit directionless in this decade. You know, we've exited our teenage years, but we don't yet feel like adults. We're seeing a lot of huge and sometimes first life changes and life events, like the end of important relationships, missed opportunities, you know, you might have lost friends or family members, you graduated uni or you've moved on to the next stage of your life. And sometimes that's met with this almost sense of, I think, blown out awareness that your life is not moving in the direction that you imagined. And like I said, it can be caused by a lot of things.
在这个十年里，很多事情都会让你感到有点迷茫。你知道，我们已经告别了青少年时期，但还没有感觉到自己像个成年人。我们正在经历许多巨大的、有时是第一次的生活变化和事件，比如重要关系的结束、错失的机会，你知道，你可能失去了朋友或家人，你大学毕业了，或者你进入了人生的下一个阶段。有时，这会带来一种我称之为“认知过载”的感觉，意识到你的生活并没有朝着你想象的方向发展。正如我所说，这可能由很多原因引起。
But I think in this day and age, social comparison through social media is a huge contributor and money, money as well, not feeling like you have enough, not feeling like you have the amount that would allow you to experience the things that you want. I think personally, I've seen this so much recently with everyone, you know, being overseas and I think I created this narrative when I was younger that my 20s and my life would be defined by travel and going places and having a lot of fun and overseas. these hostels and that hasn't really been the case. And it's really easy to feel like I've lost that sense of direction and ambition for my life. I think burnout as well, a lot of the times feeling directionless is really linked to our career, jobs we don't like, jobs we don't want. And burnout is a huge part of that.
但我认为在当今时代，社交媒体带来的社会比较是一个巨大的诱因，还有金钱，金钱也是，感觉自己拥有的不够，感觉自己没有足够的钱去体验你想要的东西。我个人认为，最近我看到大家都在海外，我年轻时曾编织过这样一个叙事：我的20多岁和人生将由旅行、去各地、在海外玩得很开心来定义。这些青年旅舍，但事实并非如此。很容易感到我已经失去了对人生的方向感和抱负。我认为倦怠也是，很多时候感到迷茫真的与我们的职业、我们不喜欢的工作、我们不想要的工作有关。而倦怠是其中的很大一部分。
And as I'll talk about later, a huge contributor to that sense of stagnation and that sense that you're not going at the pace or in the direction that you would like to be. I think it also is an entirely separate topic that deserves its own episode, the concept of burnout, and that experience as you enter into the workplace or you're exhausted by family and friendships. And sometimes, you know, you might not be quite sure why you're feeling lost. It's just this sense in your body, in your mind that you can't shake, that things are kind of aimless. You're just kind of floating from moment to moment and not really
正如我稍后会谈到的，这是导致那种停滞感以及感觉自己没有按照你想要的节奏或方向前进的一个巨大诱因。我认为这也是一个完全独立的话题，值得单独做一期节目，即倦怠的概念，以及当你进入职场或被家庭和友谊搞得精疲力竭时的那种体验。有时，你知道，你可能不太确定为什么会感到迷茫。这只是你身体里、头脑中挥之不去的一种感觉，觉得事情漫无目的。你只是在随波逐流，并没有真正
going anywhere. So there are heaps of reasons why you might be feeling lost right now, but there are also a lot of ways that you can kind of find yourself again. I think the main philosophy I'm going to be adopting in this episode is not that you need to figure out where you're going, but you need to kind of figure out who you are and what your values are, and the rest kind of falls into place. So why is this important in our 20s? I feel like that's pretty self-evident. This is the first decade of adulthood, and it's the first decade in our lives, the first time in our lives, where we might be feeling like we have real responsibility and control over where our life takes us, we have to choose the jobs that we want. Things don't just fall into our lap.
去向任何地方。所以，你现在感到迷茫的原因有很多，但也有很多方法可以让你找回自己。我认为我在这一集中将采用的主要哲学不是你需要弄清楚你要去哪里，而是你需要弄清楚你是谁以及你的价值观是什么，剩下的自然会水到渠成。那么为什么这在20多岁时很重要呢？我觉得这显而易见。这是成年后的第一个十年，也是我们生命中的第一个十年，我们第一次可能感觉到自己对人生走向负有真正的责任和控制权，我们必须选择我们想要的工作。事情不会自动掉进我们的怀里。
We don't have the structures of uni anymore, the convenience of friends that are attached to school or to some of those structures that were placed around us when we were younger. And as a result, it's really easy to sit back and feel like the vision you may have had when you were younger of where you wanted to be or the current vision that you have isn't really going along so well. I kind of also mentioned this, but big life events are extremely, extremely significant when it comes to a sense of directionless. And the definition of what a big life event is is really up to you. You know, you may have been in a string of relationships or in a relationship that,
我们不再有大学的结构，不再有依附于学校或我们年轻时被置于周围的那些结构的便利朋友。因此，很容易退后一步，觉得你年轻时对未来所持有的愿景，或者你目前的愿景，并没有那么顺利。我也提到了这一点，但重大生活事件在导致迷茫感方面极其极其重要。而什么是重大生活事件的定义完全取决于你自己。你知道，你可能经历了一连串的关系，或者一段关系，
it's ended and you're feeling like, you know, the, you know, like love or the state of your relationships isn't where you would like it to be. You might be feeling lost in terms of friendships or maybe you're stuck in a place you don't want to be physically. You're in a town or in a city that you don't love anymore. There's nothing new there. And there's that sense of, I'm stuck. I don't know where I'm going. And what the fuck am I doing? And we're here to say that's completely normal. Feeling lost in your life feels a lot like depression. They've done heaps of studies that a sense of, I don't know, exhaustion and confusion about where you're going is really tied to a lot of other mental health experiences. And if you do feel lost, you might feel
它结束了，你觉得，你知道，爱情或你的关系状态不是你想要的。你可能在友谊方面感到迷茫，或者你被困在一个你不想待的物理空间里。你在一个你不再喜欢的城镇或城市。那里没有什么新鲜事。于是产生了一种“我被困住了，我不知道我要去哪里，我到底在做什么？”的感觉。我们在这里要说，这完全正常。在生活中感到迷茫感觉很像抑郁症。他们做了大量的研究，发现一种不知道、精疲力竭和对未来方向的困惑感，确实与许多其他心理健康体验紧密相关。如果你确实感到迷茫，你可能会感到
unmotivated and uninterested in the things that make you happy, which consequently means you no longer feel or recognize yourself and it just kind of spirals from there. So it's really important to look at this topic from a holistic lens, not just in terms of organizational psychology and saying, these are the X, Y, Z steps that you need to do to get your dream job and get your dream life. Because most of the time, once you get there, there's always something better on the horizon that you want more now. So I don't really think that's the healthiest way of going about it. It's more about cultivating a relationship with yourself, which means that no matter what life kind of throws at you, the life transitions that you have to undertake, even if you do feel lost
缺乏动力，对让你快乐的事情不感兴趣，这随之意味着你不再感受或认同你自己，然后情况就会从那里开始恶化。所以，从整体的角度来看待这个话题非常重要，不仅仅是从组织心理学的角度，说这些是你需要做的X、Y、Z步骤来获得梦想工作和梦想生活。因为大多数时候，一旦你达到了那个目标，地平线上总会有你现在更想要的东西。所以我真的不认为这是最健康的处理方式。这更多是关于培养与自己的关系，这意味着无论生活给你带来什么，你必须承担的生活转变，即使你确实感到迷茫
and you are struggling with that from time to time, you can kind of see the light at the end of the tunnel and a way forward. It's going to be okay. I think that's the one thing that I really want to stress. You, if you're listening to this, I'm guessing you're in your 20, and I would just kind of invite you to think back on where you were 10 years ago. Could you have imagined your life now? And think about how young you felt then. I'm sure in 10 years' time, you're going to feel exactly the same way about your current self as you do about your past self. We are so young and you have your entire life ahead of you.
并且不时为此挣扎，你也能看到隧道尽头的曙光和前进的方向。一切都会好起来的。我认为这是我真正想强调的一点。你，如果你正在听这个，我猜你正处于20多岁，我想邀请你回想一下10年前你在哪里。你能想象你现在的生活吗？想想那时你感觉自己有多年轻。我相信10年后，你对现在的自己也会有同样的感觉，就像你对过去的自己一样。我们还很年轻，你的一生还在前方。
And this is a decade for making mistakes for trying. trying things out for not exactly knowing where you're going, but knowing it's all going to fall into place. I've experienced this quite a bit and there was this Tumblr post and I think about it all the time. So maybe it might resonate with you or make you feel better. And I can't remember the exact ages, but it kind of gives us the example of these famous people like Harrison Ford and Oprah and Merrill Streep. These people didn't find their dream careers or their dream lives until much later in life. And so you have time. There are people you haven't met yet who will be some of the deepest loves of your lives. There are opportunities that will appear when you least expect them. And many
这是一个犯错、尝试的十年。尝试各种事物，不完全知道你要去哪里，但知道一切都会水到渠成。我经历过不少这种情况，有一个Tumblr帖子，我一直都在想它。所以也许它会引起你的共鸣，或者让你感觉好一点。我不记得确切的年龄了，但它给了我们像哈里森·福特、奥普拉和梅丽尔·斯特里普这些名人的例子。这些人直到生命后期才找到他们梦想的职业或梦想的生活。所以你有时间。有些人你还没遇到，他们将成为你生命中最深沉的爱人。机会会在你最意想不到的时候出现。而许多
opportunities you'll probably get to say no to. Life, I think, just gives us many forks in the road. And the path you're on now, it won't be the same path in five years. Sorry, this is a bit of a rambling intro, but I guess I've been feeling a little bit directionless at the moment. So This is a bit of a monologue before we get into the actual psychology and science. But I look back and I was doing this for this episode. I was looking back at journals from when I first started uni. And I just thought that my life was going to turn out so much different than it actually has. And all those times that I did feel lost in the moments that led up to where I am now,
机会你可能还得学会说“不”。我认为生活只是给了我们许多岔路口。你现在走的这条路，五年后将不再是同一条路。抱歉，这是一个有点啰嗦的开场白，但我猜我最近也感到有点迷茫。所以，在进入实际的心理学和科学之前，这是一段独白。但我回顾过去，我在为这一集做准备时，回顾了刚上大学时的日记。我当时以为我的人生会比现在的结果大不相同。而在导致我走到今天这一步的那些时刻，我感到迷茫的所有时候，
I can see how it was actually steering me onto the path that. now I'm really happy with. I didn't, you know, get an internship in my last year of uni and I was super cut by it and I felt super directionless. But because that didn't happen, I did get a job I really wanted and now I live in the city. I never thought I would and I've met people so unexpectedly who have made me see the world differently and restored my confidence and love of life. And I never would have imagined that for myself and all those times I felt so lost and directionless, I can see now that there were all these things moving in the background that I couldn't have even fathomed that were kind of bringing me to a place in life where I did
我能看出它实际上是如何引导我走上我现在真正满意的道路的。我没有在大学最后一年获得实习机会，我当时非常难过，感到非常迷茫。但因为那件事没发生，我得到了一份我真正想要的工作，现在我住在这个城市。我从未想过我会住在这里，我出乎意料地遇到了一些人，他们让我以不同的方式看待世界，恢复了我的自信和对生活的热爱。我从未为自己想象过这些，而所有那些我感到如此迷茫和不知所措的时刻，我现在能看出，当时背景中有很多事情在推动，我甚至无法想象，它们正把我带到一个我确实
feel really happy. The only thing that's really promised in life, and I say this to my friends all the time, is change. So I promise you, you won't stay stagnant forever. And even if you do, you can still be happy. But enough of that. For those of you who are in a rut, I get it. I understand. So let's talk about how to move through those periods of feeling lost and feeling directionless and how to push forward big growth and big change and restore, I think just your confidence that you will find a sense of direction and a path and a journey through life that will make you happy even if you are, you know, stuck right now. So we're going to take a little bit of a different path, not an organizational path,
感到非常快乐的人生阶段。生活中唯一真正被承诺的事情，我总是对我的朋友们这样说，就是变化。所以我向你保证，你不会永远停滞不前。即使你停滞了，你仍然可以快乐。但这些就够了。对于那些处于困境中的人，我懂，我理解。所以让我们谈谈如何度过那些感到迷茫和不知所措的时期，以及如何推动巨大的成长和改变，并恢复，我想只是恢复你的自信，让你相信你会找到一种方向感、一条道路和一段旅程，即使你现在被困住了，也能让你快乐。所以我们要走一条稍微不同的路，不是组织化的道路，
not a path focused on career, but we really are going to talk. talk about positive psychology, which is perhaps my favorite domain or area of psychology, and it's so, so important when we're talking about feeling directionless. So positive psychology, for those who don't know about this kind of area of study, it's basically the scientific study of what makes life most worth living. And it focuses, you know, not on the brain, doesn't focus on your, you know, behavioral responses or mental illness or mental illness. on wellness, it focuses on individual and societal well-being and how your subjective experience of life is influenced by your individual traits, your surroundings, the institutions that make up your
不是专注于职业的道路，我们真的要谈谈积极心理学，这也许是我最喜欢的心理学领域或范畴，当我们谈论感到迷茫时，它非常非常重要。所以积极心理学，对于那些不了解这个研究领域的人来说，它基本上是对什么让生活最值得过的科学研究。它关注的不是大脑，不关注你的行为反应或精神疾病，而是关注健康，它关注个人和社会福祉，以及你对生活的个人体验如何受到你的个人特质、你的环境、构成你
life, the relationships, all with the aim of improving the quality of life. So I guess it's in the name. Positive psychology is focused really on how you can curate and build resilience and build the kind of life that you want. And it tells us, I guess you can kind of see a lot about what to do when you're feeling directionless. And it gives us advice across all domains and phases of life. So I'm going to kind of break down some of the ideas that positive psychology has had about what to do when you are at a stalemate, when you are in that stage where things aren't really moving forward. and why it's not actually about changing things in your life, but changing how you see yourself. So I read this really interesting article from the psychologist about what she does when she's in a rut.
生活的机构、人际关系的影响，所有这些都旨在提高生活质量。所以我想这就在名字里了。积极心理学真正关注的是你如何策划和建立复原力，以及建立你想要的那种生活。它告诉我们，我想你可以看出很多关于当你感到迷茫时该做什么。它在生活的所有领域和阶段都提供了建议。所以我将分解一些积极心理学关于当你处于僵局时，当你处于事情并没有真正向前发展的阶段时该做什么的想法。以及为什么这实际上不是关于改变你生活中的事情，而是改变你看待自己的方式。所以我读了一篇来自心理学家的非常有趣的文章，关于她在陷入困境时会做什么。
And there was a couple of suggestions. Having confidence in your abilities was one of them trying new things, not overthinking and not focusing on the negative. So let's kind of break these down and hopefully give you a bit of an outlook on what you can work on in yourself to get yourself out of this sense of a stalemate and the sense of not really going where you're going, not really knowing where you're going, going where you're going, well, going where you're going as well, I guess. So the first suggestion this person had, which I found really, really interesting was just having confidence in your abilities. I think the reason we sometimes
有几个建议。对自己的能力有信心是其中之一，尝试新事物，不要过度思考，不要专注于消极面。所以让我们来分解这些，希望能给你一点关于你可以如何提升自己，从而摆脱这种僵局感，以及那种不知道自己要去向何方、不知道自己要去向何方（好吧，我想也是去向何方）的感觉。所以这个人提出的第一个建议，我觉得非常非常有意思，就是对自己的能力有信心。我认为我们有时
feel directionless is because we don't really know what we offer. I found this when I was applying for jobs, And I just was like, well, I can't see myself here because I can't see myself contributing anything. But if you've always loved something and dreamed of pursuing something as a future career, or you've got ambition or you've got goals, you're a lot further along than I would say most people. And I think what's really stopping us from taking, you know, what are sometimes necessary grand leaps in life is because you're allowing insecurity and a lack of confidence in your abilities to kind of interrupt the steps you need to take to reach that a highest self and reach the point where you are content with where you're going and what's around
感到迷茫的原因是因为我们真的不知道我们能提供什么。我在申请工作时发现了这一点，我当时想，好吧，我看不出自己能在这里，因为我看不出自己能贡献什么。但如果你一直热爱某件事，并梦想着将其作为未来的职业，或者你有抱负或目标，你已经比大多数人走得远多了。我认为真正阻止我们采取那些有时是人生必要的重大飞跃的原因，是因为你让不安全感和对自己能力的缺乏信心，干扰了你为了达到那个最高自我、达到你对自己的去向和周围环境感到满足的阶段所需要采取的步骤。
you. So it's all about identifying what your strengths are. What do you bring to the table that others don't even if it's really, really small? Maybe you are really good at having conversations with other people or you're a really good listener. Maybe you're creative or you have some unique skill that, you know, not everyone has. And chances are there will be an avenue to pursue that in one way or another that can bring you happiness. It's important to identify what makes you happy, what are you good at? And how can I leverage that to kind of push my life forward? That being said, sometimes it's best to also branch out and try new things. Try a little bit of everything. That's what this person suggested. So if you have literally no idea of what you want to do,
所以这一切都是关于识别你的优势是什么。你带来了什么别人没有的东西，即使它非常非常小？也许你非常擅长与他人交谈，或者你是一个很好的倾听者。也许你很有创造力，或者你拥有某种不是每个人都有的独特技能。很有可能，会有某种途径以这样或那样的方式去追求它，从而给你带来快乐。识别什么让你快乐、你擅长什么非常重要。我该如何利用这一点来推动我的人生向前发展？话虽如此，有时最好也去拓展一下，尝试新事物。尝试一点点一切。这就是那个人建议的。所以如果你真的不知道你想做什么，
you are completely okay. That is a completely okay scenario to be in. This is the advice this person gave and I absolutely love it. When I first moved to Sydney, I was feeling really lost. I wasn't working. I didn't really have many friends here and I just tried everything and anything. Anything that pushed me out of my comfort zone. I did random little knick-knack jobs that I found on the internet. I push myself into new spaces and hobbies that I hadn't thought to pursue before. And that's exactly what you should do. Restoring confidence in your own abilities, the things that you already acknowledge yourself about yourself is one thing.
你完全没问题。这是一个完全可以接受的情况。这是那个人给出的建议，我非常喜欢。当我刚搬到悉尼时，我感到非常迷茫。我没有工作，在这里也没有什么朋友，我就尝试了一切。任何能把我推出舒适区的事情。我做了我在网上找到的各种随机的小零工。我把自己推向新的空间和爱好，这些是我以前没想过要追求的。而这正是你应该做的。恢复对自己能力的信心，那些你已经认可的关于你自己的事情是一回事。
But trying other things, you never know what you're going to be good at. And you'll probably get a confirmation of what you really want to do and the things that you're really interested in. And it will hopefully narrow it down a little bit. maybe part of trying everything is, you know, getting out there, going to new places and you realize that the thing that makes me happy is, is traveling or is being able to move around. And take that and don't forget it. Bring it into the fold of your life plan. Integrate it into what you think your future has installed.
但尝试其他事情，你永远不知道你会擅长什么。你可能会得到关于你真正想做什么以及你真正感兴趣的事情的确认。希望这能缩小范围。也许尝试一切的一部分是，你知道，走出去，去新的地方，然后你意识到让我快乐的事情是旅行，或者能够四处走动。抓住这一点，不要忘记它。把它带入你的人生规划中。把它整合到你认为未来为你准备的事情中。
Because you're the best person to be able to recognize what you really love and what your future dream life can look like based on the things. you've tried, the experiences you've had and what you've learned. Don't overthink it. It sounds really simple. I know and I hate giving advice that is so simplistic. But I think probably the worst thing that I did when I was feeling like I was in a rut was just ruminate and obsess over what I was doing wrong, how stuck I was, how I was never going to push myself forward. And those negative beliefs and there's negative self kind of self-cycling patterns of thoughts will become your reality. And the next time you need to make a big decision or try something new or apply for a job that
因为你是最能识别你真正热爱什么，以及基于你尝试过的事情、你拥有的经历和你学到的东西，你未来的梦想生活是什么样的人。不要过度思考。这听起来很简单。我知道，我讨厌给出如此简单的建议。但我认为我感到陷入困境时做的最糟糕的事情，可能就是反刍和沉迷于我做错了什么，我被困得有多深，我永远无法推动自己向前。那些消极的信念和那些消极的自我循环思维模式会成为你的现实。下一次你需要做出重大决定或尝试新事物或申请一份你认为会让你快乐的工作时，
you think will make you happy, that little voice in the back of your head that is saying, oh no, we're stuck, we're never going to move forward, isn't going to have full confidence in that decision. And you might end up, you know, not going for it or siding backwards. You shouldn't overthink it. Let life happen. yourself be in the moment because big changes are really scary and so is feeling stuck and lost. But if it feels right, just do it, just overthink it. Take that random job. I always think of my friend Meg who moves around and just does the most amazing things because she just jumps at it and she doesn't look back. I think this goes hand in hand with the next piece of advice that
你脑海中那个说“哦不，我们被困住了，我们永远无法向前”的小声音，就不会对那个决定有充分的信心。你最终可能会，你知道，不去争取或向后退。你不应该过度思考。让生活发生。让自己活在当下，因为巨大的改变真的很可怕，感到被困住和迷茫也很可怕。但如果感觉对了，就去做，不要过度思考。接受那份随机的工作。我总是想到我的朋友Meg，她四处走动，只是做着最棒的事情，因为她只是跳进去，从不回头。我认为这与积极心理学可能给那些现在感到有点被困住的人的下一个建议相辅相成。
positive psychology might give those of us who are feeling a little bit stuck right now. Don't focus on the negatives. That is a lot harder for some people versus others, especially those who are just naturally pessimistic. I think we often see people who have a negative outlook on life as having some kind of control over that, but there are just people who think that way. They're optimists and they're pessimists in the world, which is totally fine. We love our differences on this podcast. But if you are someone who, you know, kind of always sees things as not working out or is really pessimistic about your future or what might grow right for you and you're focusing on what might go wrong. It's important that you kind of don't focus on that internal voice, but focus more on
不要专注于消极面。这对某些人来说比其他人要难得多，尤其是那些天生悲观的人。我认为我们经常看到那些对生活持消极态度的人，认为他们对那种态度有某种控制权，但确实有人就是那样思考的。世界上有乐观主义者，也有悲观主义者，这完全没问题。在这个播客上，我们热爱我们的差异。但如果你是一个，你知道，总是认为事情不会成功，或者对你的未来或什么可能对你有利非常悲观，并且你专注于什么可能出错的人。重要的是，你不要专注于那个内在的声音，而是更多地专注于
external reward and pursuing things that validate a different belief in your mind that things can get better and things will go right for you. One way that a lot of psychologists suggest doing this is through scheduling positive reinforcement around your goals so that when you are struggling with where you're going, you don't fall back on thinking that life sucks and isn't going to give you what you want. So scheduling positive reinforcement might involve rewarding yourself when you take actions towards the life that you want, even if they're small. And making it so that you're not just dependent on fate and good luck and factors outside your control to feel positive about your choices. So those are some of the pieces of advice that positive psychology
外部奖励，追求那些能验证你脑海中不同信念的事情，即事情会好转，事情会为你顺利进行。很多心理学家建议这样做的一种方法是，围绕你的目标安排积极强化，这样当你为自己的去向而挣扎时，你就不会陷入认为生活很糟糕、不会给你想要的东西的想法中。所以安排积极强化可能包括当你采取行动朝着你想要的生活迈进时奖励自己，即使它们很小。并做到这一点，这样你就不会仅仅依赖命运、好运和超出你控制的因素来对你的选择感到积极。所以这些是积极心理学
kind of gives to us. But there are some other more meditative practices, I would say, more mindful practices that we see across a few domains of psychology that I think are really also important to integrate into this and into our personal narratives around when we're getting stuck. So we've talked about what positive psychology can do for us, but what about kind of a different vein. I really want to talk about the role of values in recentering our lives and giving us direction because this is something that I think is a lot more tangible. It's not around, you know, how you feel about yourself and your thoughts and your experiences, but is direct actions and kind of a really, yeah, an actionable way to restore your faith in yourself that everything
给我们的一些建议。但还有一些更冥想的练习，我会说，更正念的练习，我们在心理学的几个领域中都能看到，我认为将这些整合到这一点以及我们关于陷入困境时的个人叙事中也非常重要。我们已经谈论了积极心理学能为我们做什么，但另一种思路呢？我真的想谈谈价值观在重新定位我们的生活并给我们方向方面的作用，因为我认为这更具体。它不是关于，你知道，你对自己、你的想法和你的经历的感觉，而是直接的行动，是一种真正可操作的方式来恢复你对自己的一切的信心，
is, you know, going to be okay. You're going to figure it out. I saw someone explain this really well and why our sense of value, our values as well, not just our sense of value, but our values, our sense of mission and passion and connection in life is really important in these kind of tough times that I'm sure many of you are experiencing right now. It's also about separating yourself from external things. You are not just work. You are not just your career. I say this to myself all the time when I'm feeling really burnt out or feeling, you know, really stuck in my job. You're not just how much money you have either and you're not just your relationships. You are made up of many, many amazing and individual components that aren't always externally motivated or externally driven, but are just as
你知道，一切都会好起来的。你会弄明白的。我看到有人很好地解释了这一点，以及为什么我们的价值感，我们的价值观，不仅仅是我们的价值感，而是我们的价值观，我们的使命感、激情和生活中的联系，在这些我确信你们许多人现在正在经历的艰难时期非常重要。这也是关于将自己与外部事物分离开来。你不仅仅是工作。你不仅仅是你的职业。当我感到非常精疲力竭或感到，你知道，在工作中真的被困住时，我总是对自己这样说。你也不仅仅是你拥有多少钱，你也不仅仅是你的关系。你由许多许多惊人的、独立的组成部分组成，它们并不总是外部驱动的，但同样
important and really important to rest and to kind of rely on in times like this. So this person, I thought this was a really interesting concept. They describe this idea of a win. And your win is kind of the thing or the essence of yourself that will help you get out of a rut and, you know, center back on what you have to offer, where you want to go and what you're doing. So your win, Wynn is kind of interchangeable with your sense of self is comprised of these five elements. So mission, profession, connection, passion and vibration. This sounds really spiritual, but I promise it's tangible as well. And quite scientific.
重要，在这样的时刻真的非常重要，可以去依靠。所以这个人，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的概念。他们描述了这个“赢”（win）的想法。你的“赢”就是那种能帮助你摆脱困境，并重新聚焦于你所能提供的、你想去的地方以及你正在做的事情的本质。所以你的“赢”，Wynn，可以与你的自我感互换，由这五个要素组成：使命（mission）、职业（profession）、联系（connection）、激情（passion）和振动（vibration）。这听起来很精神，但我保证它也是具体的。而且相当科学。
A lot of psychologists and psychology as a field of study identify that our sense of self is not a singular thing. it's made up of a lot of different aspects. And rarely do you find someone whose mission, profession, connection, passion and vibration all align. So they're all equally important and you can't be neglecting one or the other. So let's just break down what these are and why it's important to really write down and state exactly what these five elements of yourself mean to you if you're trying to push yourself into the next chapter. So your mission is kind of your overarching objective. It's the why in your question of existence. I know this feels really scary, but it's kind of your guide star. It's going to tell you what kind of course of action and what course you want
许多心理学家和心理学作为一个研究领域认为，我们的自我感不是单一的东西。它由许多不同的方面组成。你很少会发现一个人的使命、职业、联系、激情和振动都完全一致。所以它们同样重要，你不能忽视其中任何一个。所以让我们分解一下这些是什么，以及如果你正试图推动自己进入下一个篇章，为什么真正写下并陈述这五个要素对你意味着什么非常重要。你的使命是你总体上的目标。它是你存在问题中的“为什么”。我知道这感觉很可怕，但它有点像你的指路明灯。它会告诉你什么样的行动方针以及你想采取什么样的路线
to take to reach that kind of ideal self and that ideal life that we're all kind of striving towards. Your mission can be really, really simple. And it can be whatever you want it to be. Maybe your mission is to become a doctor. Your mission is to travel as much as you can. your mission is to start a family. Maybe your mission is just to have a lot of friends, to be happy to live in nature, whatever you want it to be. It is the one thing that you can rest back on and say, even if everything else goes to shit.
来达到我们都在努力追求的那种理想自我和理想生活。你的使命可以非常非常简单。它可以是你想要的任何东西。也许你的使命是成为一名医生。你的使命是尽可能多地旅行。你的使命是组建一个家庭。也许你的使命只是拥有很多朋友，快乐地生活在大自然中，无论你想要它是什么。它是你可以依靠的一件事，并说，即使其他一切都搞砸了。
Like, this is my goal. This is where I'm heading. Your profession is kind of the application of your unique skills in a manner that, you know, typically serves the mission, but not always. So it's kind of the things you'd put on your resume if you were applying. for a job or it might be your job. It's the kind of things in your life that make up your working life and your career and yeah, the application of skills is probably the best way to say it. And it kind of links back to the having confidence in your own self and having confidence in
就像，这是我的目标。这是我前进的方向。你的职业有点像以一种通常服务于使命的方式应用你独特的技能，但不总是这样。所以它有点像如果你申请工作时会写在简历上的东西，或者它可能是你的工作。它是你生活中构成你工作生活和职业生涯的东西，是的，应用技能可能是最好的说法。它有点回到了对自己有信心和对
your skills. So your profession is the things that you can identify that make you valuable. Maybe it's writing, maybe it's speaking, maybe it is like very distinct. you know, characteristics, attributes, whatever you want to call them, like your job. Maybe it's your job title. Maybe it's, you know, the volunteer experience you had. It's the tangible things that you can say, okay, this is what I've done, this is what I have, and this is what is different and important about me. Often they're applied to your career as the word profession kind of says, but if you're
自己的技能有信心。所以你的职业是你能够识别出的让你有价值的东西。也许是写作，也许是演讲，也许是像非常独特的，你知道，特征、属性，无论你想怎么称呼它们，比如你的工作。也许是你的职称。也许是，你知道，你的志愿者经历。它是你可以说“好吧，这就是我做过的，这就是我拥有的，这就是我与众不同且重要的地方”的具体事物。通常它们被应用于你的职业，正如“职业”这个词所说，但如果你是
someone who that's not really part of your own goal, they can be, as unique and different as you want them to be. But they're your skills. Next, you have your passion. And your passion, as you could kind of sense, might be different from your mission and your profession. Your passions transcend. They kind of transcend the things that we feel required to do and the things that we are excited to do. And you don't always have to derive some kind of, you know, money or worth or direct kind of impact on your mission from these. You know, you might just really like knitting or fishing and that might be your passion. You don't need to make money off of it. It's not going anywhere. You can just do it and enjoy it. Like for me, it's rock climbing. It's making this podcast.
一个那并不是你个人目标一部分的人，它们可以像你想要的那样独特和不同。但它们是你的技能。接下来，你有你的激情。而你的激情，正如你可能感觉到的，可能与你的使命和职业不同。你的激情超越了。它们有点超越了我们觉得被要求做的事情和我们感到兴奋的事情。你并不总是需要从中获得某种，你知道，金钱或价值或对你的使命的直接影响。你知道，你可能只是真的很喜欢编织或钓鱼，那可能就是你的激情。你不需要从中赚钱。它不会去任何地方。你只需要做它并享受它。比如对我来说，是攀岩。是制作这个播客。
This podcast, you know, it's, you know, as much as it's important to me, I have a job outside of this. It's not my mission. It's just something that I really love doing that. makes me enthusiastic. And it's the application of my profession and of my skills. So it builds me up in a way that's different to my career and different to my long-term goals, but it's still important because it makes me feel good. And it kind of creates an identity that's separate from my working life and separate from my relationships and from other things that feel really immovable. Your passion is kind of the deeper essence of who you are. And that brings us to connection. Connection is the relationships you have with others.
这个播客，你知道，它，你知道，尽管它对我来说很重要，但我在这之外还有一份工作。它不是我的使命。它只是我真正喜欢做的事情，让我充满热情。它是我的职业和我的技能的应用。所以它以一种不同于我的职业和不同于我的长期目标的方式建立了我，但它仍然很重要，因为它让我感觉良好。它创造了一种独立于我的工作生活、独立于我的关系以及其他感觉真的不可动摇的事物的身份。你的激情有点像你是谁的更深层本质。这把我们带到了联系。联系是你与他人的关系。
These are important to think about when you're feeling like you're lost or you're feeling like you're directionless because chances are there are people who are looking at you thinking that you have everything together, people who love you as well. And that sense of connection, even in times of feeling really lost, is important to think back on and to think about and to kind of bring. to the actions that you want to take to achieve your goals. Even if everything goes wrong, you know, you might still have that amazing relationship with your best friend or with your parents.
当你感到迷茫或感到不知所措时，思考这些很重要，因为很有可能有人看着你，认为你一切都处理得很好，也有人爱你。那种联系感，即使在感到非常迷茫的时候，在回想和思考时也很重要，并将其带入你想要采取的行动中以实现你的目标。即使一切都出了问题，你知道，你可能仍然拥有与你最好的朋友或父母的那种惊人的关系。
You will always have people that love you and will support you and who you can enjoy and spend time around. So the final element of our win, of the things that make up our self and which are important to really think about and ponder when you're thinking about the direction of your life is your vibration. It's the state of being that extends way beyond your relationships. It extends beyond your profession, your passion, and your mission. And it's kind of how you represent yourself to the world, not in terms of your skills,
你总会有爱你、支持你的人，你可以享受并与他们共度时光。所以我们“赢”的最后一个要素，即构成我们自我、并且在思考人生方向时真正需要思考和琢磨的事情，是你的振动。它是超越了你关系的生存状态。它超越了你的职业、你的激情和你的使命。它有点像你如何向世界展示自己，不是就你的技能而言，
not in terms of your relationship, but in terms of your vibration. What are you kind of bringing to the world? Are you a happy, bubbly person? Do you have this kind of warm energy? How would you see yourself through the eyes of others? And what kind of energy do you bring? into spaces. Vibration to me, it's kind of probably the most important, although I know I said none of them are more important than the other, but it is completely separate from, you know,
不是就你的关系而言，而是就你的振动而言。你带给世界的是什么？你是一个快乐、活泼的人吗？你有一种温暖的能量吗？你会如何通过他人的眼睛看待自己？你带给空间的是什么样的能量？对我来说，振动，它可能是最重要的，虽然我知道我说过它们没有哪个比另一个更重要，但它与，你知道，
it's obviously related, but it's separate from the other things. No matter what happens in your life, you get to choose the energy that you bring to your endeavors and that you bring to your life and the passion that you have and the things that you enjoy and the things that you notice. So your vibration is kind of that sense of where you're standing in the world and what you kind of want to put forth. So this psychologist says that it's really important to focus on all of them at the same time in times when you are feeling a little bit lost because it allows you to find meaning beyond the things that we normally feel directionless about like work, like education, like careers. And recognize that your sense of self is tied to, you know, many, many,
它显然是相关的，但它与别的东西是分开的。无论你的生活中发生什么，你都可以选择你带给你的努力、带给你的生活的能量，以及你拥有的激情，你享受的事情，你注意到的事情。所以你的振动有点像你站在世界上的那种感觉，以及你想要展现出的东西。所以这位心理学家说，在感到有点迷茫的时候，同时关注所有这些非常重要，因为它让你找到超越我们通常感到迷茫的事情（如工作、教育、职业）的意义。并认识到你的自我感与，你知道，许多许多，
other things, who you present, you know, how you present to the world, the person you are, it doesn't always have to be about what you're achieving and where you're going, but about the, you know, but about how you treat others, the connection you have with others, where you find enjoyment. So the way that I bring this kind of idea of the win into steering myself back onto the course that I want is through this journaling exercise that I find so fulfilling. And as a it also kind of serves as a really good real-time indicator of what's kind of going on in my life, what I want and what I'm achieving. So there's this, it's this journaling exercise and it asks you to think about your life in three months. Picture what your ideal self in three, maybe even six
还有其他方面，比如你如何展现自己，你向世界呈现出的样子，你是一个怎样的人。这并不总是关于你取得了什么成就，或者你要去向何方，而是关于你如何对待他人，你与他人的联系，以及你在哪里找到快乐。所以我将这种“赢”的理念融入到我重回正轨的方法中，就是通过这个让我感到非常充实的日记练习。它也像是一个非常好的实时指标，反映了我生活中正在发生的事情，我想要什么，以及我正在实现什么。所以，这是一个日记练习，它让你思考三个月后的生活。想象一下三个月，甚至六个月后你理想中的自己是什么样子
months. What are they doing? Who are they surrounded by? How are they making, I don't know, money? What are their passions and what brings them happiness? Sit down. and plan out the key elements of what your life looks like. So for me, I did this a couple of months ago and I said, in six months time, I'm going to have, you know, 50,000 listens on the podcast. And I'm going to have amazing friends in this new city. It's almost like a manifestation. This is what I want.
他们在做什么？身边有哪些人？他们是如何，我不知道，赚钱的？他们的热情所在是什么，什么能给他们带来快乐？坐下来，规划出你生活样子的关键要素。对我来说，几个月前我做了这个练习，我说，六个月后，我的播客要达到5万次收听。而且在这个新城市，我会有很棒的朋友。这几乎就像是一种显化。这就是我想要的。
And the next part of the exercise is more tricky. But if you push it, you'll find that it's not as difficult as you think. Think about how you can reach that state. what exactly are the actions you need to take, even if they're small, that's going to allow you to realize that ambition for your life. Really think about it. If, you know, your job, if you want, you know, one of your pictures of your life in six, three months, whatever you choose, is I'm going to be working in a job that I really love. The actions would be, you know, apply and try different jobs. Try different jobs. Think about and identify what's important to me in a job.
练习的下一部分比较棘手。但如果你努力去想，你会发现它并不像你想象的那么难。思考一下你如何才能达到那种状态。你需要采取的具体行动是什么，即使是很小的行动，也能让你实现人生的抱负。真的好好想想。如果，你知道，你的工作，如果你想要，你知道，你六个月或三个月后生活图景中的一部分是“我将从事一份我真正热爱的工作”。那么行动就是，你知道，申请并尝试不同的工作。尝试不同的工作。思考并确定什么对我来说是重要的工作。
think about what makes me happy and what I want to do and what I derive enjoyment out of. If it's being around animals, you kind of know that having a job that you love in six months probably needs to involve some element of that. If you love being outdoors, you know, a bad action would probably be to start applying for office jobs because it's unlikely that's going to allow you to reach that goal, that six-month goal, of having a job that you like. So if you are feeling directionless, it's something that I really recommend. is just sitting with your vision and your thoughts of what you want in the future and writing it down,
思考什么让我快乐，我想做什么，我能从中获得什么乐趣。如果是因为喜欢和动物在一起，你就知道六个月后你热爱的工作可能需要包含这方面的因素。如果你喜欢户外活动，你知道，一个糟糕的行动可能就是开始申请办公室工作，因为这不太可能让你实现那个目标，那个六个月后拥有一份你喜欢的工作的目标。所以如果你感到迷茫，我真的推荐这个方法：静下心来，带着你对未来的愿景和想法，把它写下来，
writing exactly as explicit and detailed as possible. What do you want? Even if it's grand, even if it doesn't seem achievable. Where do you want to be in six months? What are you doing in that day? In six months' time on a Tuesday or a Wednesday, what is your daily life like? And how can you get there? what are the actions you need to take? And I promise you things kind of fall into place.
尽可能详细、明确地写下来。你想要什么？即使它很宏大，即使它看起来无法实现。六个月后你想在哪里？那天你在做什么？六个月后的某一个周二或周三，你的日常生活是什么样的？你如何才能到达那里？你需要采取什么行动？我向你保证，事情会各就各位的。
I think also people notice when you're trying to get yourself out of the rut and opportunities will fall into your lap as you work towards them. I think this is a shorter episode, but that's really all I wanted to say. That's what I wanted to talk about. It's more of just my thoughts on this topic because it's something I've been feeling. I've been feeling just super burnt out. And for the first time, I think in a while not having a clear vision or goal of where I want my life to be. But that's also super freeing because I know that this is the time when I can try many, many things and fall back on my relationships and screw up and fuck up and quit jobs and do whatever I want. And it's all going to be all right because this is the decade for making mistakes and figuring things out. So if you're feeling
我也认为，当你试图走出困境时，人们会注意到，当你朝着目标努力时，机会就会降临到你身上。我觉得这一集比较短，但这确实是我所有想说的。这就是我想谈论的。这更多是我对这个话题的一些想法，因为这是我最近的感受。我一直感到非常精疲力竭。而且这是很久以来第一次，我没有一个清晰的愿景或目标，不知道我想让我的生活变成什么样。但这也非常令人解脱，因为我知道现在是我可以尝试很多很多事情的时候，我可以依靠我的人际关系，搞砸事情，犯错，辞职，做任何我想做的事。一切都会好起来的，因为这是犯错和摸索的十年。所以如果你感到
directionless, I get it. But I also would like to remind you that you are not alone. So, many people during this time feel exactly the same way and so many people before you have as well and it always always works out. Thank you for listening to this smaller, shorter, but hopefully enjoyable episode. As always, if you have enjoyed it, please leave a review if you feel cool to do so on either Apple, podcast or Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. It really helps the podcast grow and reach new people. And it makes my day to see that people like this. I don't know. I record these in my bedrooms. I write these scripts on my little laptop. And it is my passion. It's part of my win. So getting that kind of feedback that people like it and that it's
迷茫，我理解。但我也想提醒你，你并不孤单。在这个时期，很多人都有同样的感受，在你之前也有很多人经历过，而且一切总会好起来的。感谢收听这一集较短、但希望你喜欢的节目。一如既往，如果你喜欢的话，如果你愿意，请在Apple Podcasts或Spotify，或者你现在收听的任何地方留下评论。这真的有助于播客的成长并触达更多新听众。看到人们喜欢它，这让我的一天都很美好。我不知道。我在卧室里录制这些节目。我在我的小笔记本电脑上写这些脚本。这是我的热情所在。这是我“赢”的一部分。所以得到人们喜欢它的反馈，并且它
resonating with people not only makes me feel really happy, but less alone in this kind of weird, weird time. So thank you again for all of the support. And I will see you next week. when we're talking about situationships. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
能引起人们的共鸣，不仅让我感到非常快乐，而且在这个奇怪的时期，让我感到不再那么孤单。再次感谢大家的支持。我们下周见，届时我们将讨论“情境关系”。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%.
但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
这是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。